if you're here and you want something to
happen the fastest and most significant
way to grow a business in 2023 and 24
besides the operational part to grow a
business it's called social media I I
don't know if you heard it's free
everyone's always mad at it the [__]
thing is free attention is the number
one
asset thank you thank you thank you
that's some real love San Diego I
appreciate you how you
doing all right let's get into it so
much to talk about um when when I think
about talks on the way to them I try to
think about like what today as I'm sure
actually by by some noise how many of
you consume some of my
content so you can imagine the thing I
think a lot about when I speak is if I'm
putting out so much and I'm putting it
out every day what can I actually bring
in value that might be a little bit
different and so it's why I really love
Q&A but what is also interesting about
what I do for a living is like the sign
said earlier I think a lot about day
trading attention because I think when I
look at a room like this the reality is
is that no matter what you do in here
whether that's B2B B Toc if you're an
entrepreneur if you're an employee
Fitness industry wine industry sneakers
it really is not any difference to me
because the reality is if I talk about
attention it is relevant to everyone in
here including people that are running
for local office for people that are
trying to raise money for their favorite
charity for people that are trying to
impact their school the thing that I've
been obsessed with since I was selling
lemonade at seven years old and on a
stage like this maybe 10 years ago I
realized man I don't even really
remember pouring the lemonade and I had
an epiphany that when I had lemonade
stands my friends would hold down the
lemonade stand and I would walk around
the streets of New Jersey and try to
figure out where to put my signs I've
been chasing attention my whole life and
so baseball cards went well for me
because I gave thought to how my table
looked at the show my dad's liquor store
was real easy for me I would watch
people walk in the store and I would pay
attention to how they would move and I
changed the way our setup was and I made
sure the stuff we wanted to sell was in
front of them instead of somewhere they
couldn't find as you can imagine when I
launched wine library.com a website it's
crazy the fact that I launched wine
library.com in 199 how many people here
were not born in 1997 Make Some
[Music]
Noise getting [__] old getting old up
here the fact that I launched a website
in 1997 actually I'm writing a new book
called day trading attention that will
come out next year and on the flight
here for 5 hours I we were editing it
and there was something about YouTube we
were talking about YouTube in it and I
made a
reference in there of when I started and
in the reference it said that I started
Wine Library TV five months after
YouTube came out and I thought that was
too soon so we looked it up and it was
actually wrong but the other direction
Youtube came out I think December 15
2005 I launched Wine Library TV February
21st 2006 and it's probably the thing
that what I'm setting up here for you is
it's kind of scary how big the
opportunity is for everybody in this
room regardless of where you're at if
you actually make a commitment to what I
now recognize is the commitment that
I've made my whole life and very
aggressively for the last 20 years which
is if you actually understand where
people's attention is and then you
actually figure out how to storytelling
those platforms whether in the written
word in video or in audio and most of
all which I think [__] up most people
you stay patient and try to actually
bring value not extract value when you
know it takes me two seconds when I go
to the airport somebody rolls up they're
like Gary ve I'm not [__] growing
like it takes me 100th of a second to
know why because they're only about
themselves they care about how many
followers they get they care about how
many likes they get they care about how
many [__] things they
sell there's just like literally no
relationship with the audience I know I
get to stand up here I know I get this
love for you it matters to me to provide
value I'm not scared to be a businessman
I got sneakers to sell and books to sell
and wine to sell and be friends to like
I'm not scared but I don't understand
how people don't understand what's
happening The Whole World's competing
now every single person's competing with
every single person every business and
how are you going to break through
you're not going to break through by so
showing the same [__] a billion people
are posting a [__] flexy
watch that shit's not going to break
through I I think that most of us in
general need to understand the the the
science behind the game and the game is
attention on this device there's eight
or nine platforms that dominate this
thing and the question to me that I
always think about when I look around
the by the way that lime sweatshirt
you're wearing is fire
fire can we clap it up for can you stand
up it's
[Applause]
nice atten listen [__] caught my [__]
eye look
listen it's the same [__] for the last
years like marketing is how you grow a
business right obviously the product has
to be good but you have to get out there
and create demand for your business
right you could do it through Word of
Mouth you could be great at what you do
and people talk about that's great but
if you want to accelerate and I have no
idea I mean there's no reason anyone's
in this Auditorium right now you know on
this Thursday
unless they're trying to grow so I'm
just defaulting into thinking everybody
here has ambition and hunger and trying
to do [__] so I know everyone here is
trying to do something what I'm always
confused by is why we keep looking for
some sort of shortcut my famous my
favorite entrepreneurs are Fitness
entrepreneurs Fitness entrepreneurs make
me laugh so much because unless they
cheat which I know a lot of [__]
people do they know the way to do it is
the discipline like you got to do the
exercise properly you've got to do it
every [__] day or often and you've
got to eat properly like people know how
to get into better
shape there's no [__] secret I mean
there's no benic or whatever the [__]
that [__] is now but you know like the
right way to do it is pretty simple with
the gym and with your fork and spoon but
it's hard to do but Fitness
entrepreneurs are always like rolling up
they're like yo but yeah but how how do
I do it fast and I'm like you spend your
day every day teaching people that there
is no fast physically but you're looking
for fast
business-wise the reason I pound
patients and I know I watch the data I
know how many of you are tired and have
no interest in me telling you it takes
time I get why everybody wants it fast
everybody wants it fast because the
world's
insecure everybody wants to win fast
because they want to show everybody else
that they won I understand you want to
prove it to the girl that didn't [__]
with you in high
school I get that you want to prove it
to your dad who never said you had it I
understand all this [__] all this
business stuff it's all this it's always
this I understand fake it to you make it
I understand I'm watching it all it's
all I do all I do for life is watch
people Nothing confused me about people
I understand you all I get it the
problem is it's the same [__] every time
for
example the thing that breaks my heart
is that people actually think money
makes you happy I know what people say
when they don't have it they're like
cool give it to me and I'll figure it
out I get
it how many people here have rich
friends Make some
noise of the people that just made noise
how many you have rich friends that you
know right now are super [__] up super
unhappy drugs alcohol all sorts of [__]
Make some noise
that all of them all of them you're
right bro bro honestly on some real [__]
one of the advantages of growing up in
the dirt and coming up a certain way is
you have lots of friends and a lot of
family that you know live not in a
millionaire lifestyle and you watch I
wish some of my millionaire friends
could have the lifestyle of some of my
high school friends that are deeply
happy but don't make the same level of
paper money doesn't make you happier
money exposes
you money and fame exposed they don't
change he changed he didn't change you
didn't know
him now you know him you understand so
that's a whole separate thing but on
this business front I'll give you you
know maybe I had it right with my first
book my first book subtitle of crush it
was cashing in on your passion maybe
what was clear to me in my early 30s has
become again very clear to me as I get
closer to 50 I don't know how you can
work hard enough to beat your comp
competition if you don't like the thing
you're doing I watch every day for the
last 20 years people chase whatever
current Trend they think they can make
money in real estate every eight years
crypto
cannabis like social media influencer
like I've watched people's profile on
Twitter over the last 15 years change
nine times of what expert they
are you can't win if you don't like it
because somebody else likes it and
they're going to outwork
you you can't it's not sustainable
unless you love the [__] process it's
too hard to be an
entrepreneur I know it got cool cuz I'm
47 I remember when it wasn't cool I'm a
direct beneficiary of it becoming cool
this is like a different this is not the
life I
expected businessmen were just behind
the scenes and you lived and you built
businesses I understand understand that
it's pop culture now I understand that
people aspire to it but if I could wish
anything for everybody in this room as I
look corner to corner besides health I
would wish you
self-awareness there's a lot of people
sitting in here wanting or are
delusional that they're a great
entrepreneur and what they really are is
a great number two and a great number
three the number four at Facebook and
Tesla made a lot more money than 99.9%
of the number ones that started
companies
thanks
Mom
self-awareness everybody's so focused on
what they wish they could be that
they're not paying attention to who they
are so I thank you I
seriously let me tell you why I
understand all my Spiel to be true
because I've been putting out and
millions of other people have been
putting out the direct black and white
content to make it work there's
unlimited content on how to build a
business what the right tactics are how
to use Shopify how to use WordPress how
to use eBay how to use Tik Tok there's
unlimited
content the reason I started to overtime
evolve into like I got to figure this
out because why hasn't everyone figured
it out you start realizing it has
nothing to do with the
tactics literally literally there's
nothing from a knowledge standpoint when
it comes to business that isn't
available for
free I don't know if you've heard about
Google or chat
GPT or YouTube use those three free
products and you can get the direct
answer I don't know what the [__] you're
doing with your notebooks out
here there's nothing to write down
it's all
here it's not the
tactics right look there's a lot to the
tactics let me segue to the tactics for
a second do I believe and I look at like
a lot of times when I come out to a talk
I'll look on social to see who's here
what you're talking about then I'll look
at the profiles try to get a sense of
the feel do I believe that most people
here don't understand the science of
social media the answer is yes do I
believe when I look at all of the
accounts I looked at over the last
couple days hyped for this event or here
or what have you that when I I look at
your profile I'm like oh they don't
understand that the thumbnail has no
shot or oh [__] they're one of those
people that think on Instagram you just
it's all about the picture of the video
and they put no effort into the copy
which is why it's not happening for them
do do I look at Tik Tok and be like oh
they just posted their Instagram reel on
Tic Tac or vice versa that's why they
don't get it do I think that there's
extraordinary science behind the art I
do the thumbnail matters the first three
seconds matter the style matters if you
if you're still doing what you did for
like how many people here are stagnant
in their growth on Instagram and don't
be full of [__] raise your hand because
I want everybody to see this actually
stand up please on some real [__] what's
a question are you stagnant on your
growth on Instagram put on the
lights no no no no this is good by the
way I'm
standing I'm
standing so thank you everybody I wanted
everybody to visualize it actually if
you can keep those lights on that'd be
epic because the dark freaks me out
it really it doesn't I just like seeing
the faces for reaction listen to me the
reason everybody stood up is all that
social media is is supply and demand my
favorite thing is like Gary you need to
help me I've been Shadow banned no you
haven't Don you just
suck nobody here is Shadow
banned you're not Shadow banned you just
haven't changed up your game in the last
three years and there's more people
posting on the platform than ever and
some of the attention is now fully just
on Tik Tok it's called [__] supply
and
demand you remember when I was yelling
and going crazy 5 years ago telling you
get on Tik Tok and you're like nah [__]
that [__] that's girls that dance that
are 14 you [__]
up this game is simple but hard just
like getting into better shape there are
core platforms that have the world's
attention almost everybody here does not
post three times a day on LinkedIn
everybody here should post three times a
day on LinkedIn
I don't care if you sell t-shirts I
don't care if you sell peach ice cream
LinkedIn is not what it was when we all
came out the gate it's no longer a
recruiting tool it is a social network
that has crazy organic reach that has
very high value customers that are
usually at work when they're in it so
they're paying attention even more
because they don't want to
work and so you know I can go around the
world and speak and I can put out the
content but when I was thinking about
this I'm like look I can go into the
tactics you know I can tell you right
now that on Instagram if you post an
image first and a second Carousel video
instead of just a reals video like we've
all been doing it will do better there
you go go good go write that [__] down
on your [__]
Pad but what I know is that when you do
it seven times or 12 times and it
doesn't go cuz the quality of the
content wasn't good enough that you
stop and so I guess for me at this point
I'm just trying to figure out what are
people worried about what's stopping
people and it's all the same cliche [__]
some people don't like the way they look
on camera but you don't like the way you
look on camera because for some reason
you've decided to
value a strangers [__] comment on
you coming from their own hurt instead
of the way you feel about your own
self like the thought of how many people
here don't want someone from their high
school or college or a neighbor or
coworker or even worse the thing that
kills me that you literally are not
building your future because you're
worried about Johnny pants
67 coming on your
account and [__] [__] on you do
you understand how sad of a life it is
to spend your time at night laying in
your bed going around your feed seeing
someone's bright light and you're in
such a bad place that you want to say
you suck or you're wrong or [__] you you
shouldn't be feeling bad for yourself
you need to feel bad for these people we
need more empathy like this is someone
who's hurt anyone I the thought of
spending a second of my time to hurt
someone else's feelings is [__]
insane to
me
beautiful so I'm just going to you know
I'm trying to systematically think about
like why won't you post 33 like if
you're here and you want something to
happen the fastest and most significant
way to grow a business in 2023 and 24
besides the operational part besides the
fact that it has to be able to
operate to grow a business it's called
social
media I I don't know if you heard it's
free everyone's always mad at at it the
[__] thing is
free I built my Daddy's Liquor Store not
with social media I built it with
newspaper ads [__] cost
money television commercials that were
local we didn't have that kind of money
that cost
money [__]
Billboards those [__] took my
money Google AdWords killed for me but
it was still [__]
money this shit's free and I don't know
if you paid mention what happened the
last two years in Social it changed
social for the first 10 years was based
on the social graph now it's based on
the interest graph let me explain the
first 10 12 years of social media was
more like email marketing you amassed
people to follow you you post and a
percentage of them opened right they saw
it now the algorithms are taking over
and it's around interest there are
people in this room who've never been on
Tik Tok who can leave this conference
and say [__] it I'll F Gary got me I'll
do it let me go and their first post
with zero followers can get 8,000 20,000
100,000 a million views that's real that
happens every day that's insane not only
is it
free it actually is being seen unlike
all my clients who continue to buy TV
commercials who here seen a [__] TV
commercial ever besides the Super
Bowl we we don't even watch regular TV
and cable TV anymore every one of you
[__] have four subscri you complain
about money but you have six
subscriptions to every streaming service
you haven't been on [__] HBO Max in a
Years YouTube social streaming we don't
even watch those things so look there's
such an outrageous level of opportunity
right now and it's a game of the Hales
and Have Nots meaning either you see it
AKA either you decide the world sucks
and everything's hard and there's a lot
going on I get it or you decide not like
sometimes when someone's complaining and
as my homie I give them my phone and I'm
like look at my stream My Stream is like
[__] kittens kissing each other like
the [__] sun coming out my stream's
positive as [__] because I protect my
[__]
sanity
no [__] you're going to be upset if you
only consume negativity no [__] you're
going to be upset if the core people in
your life spend 100% of their time
complaining and it's hard almost all of
us have either a negative mom or dad
that's already hard and that shit's hard
but I remind my friends I'm like you're
40 you're going to still complain and
blame Mommy and Daddy for
everything instead of buying a [__]
Maserati go get therapy
[Applause]
[Music]
dick and I get not everybody can afford
therapy but
exercise free meditation apps like just
genuinely putting positivity in your
ears instead of negativity the number
one thing the world lost was
accountability we've gotten so good at
telling everybody else in the world what
they should be doing we we love pointing
fingers right how about thumbs where the
[__] have thumbs
gone let me give you the biggest
indication that you're a [__] loser
entrepreneur G to give it to you right
now you blame the current president for
your
[Applause]
[Music]
[__] I love that I'm an entrepreneur I'm
an entrepreneur and then you're blaming
the
president you [__]
suck as
if I've made plenty of money as an
entrepreneur with Republicans and plenty
with Democrats give me an independent
and I'll Crush I don't give a
[__] that's
right people make me laugh people talk
real [__] but then we just aren't
accountable here's another one how many
people have more than 10 employees raise
your
hands good
let me tell you the funniest thing about
running a
company
100% of the [__] that's wrong is your
fault it's crazy I sat like I sit with
my homies I read all the DMS I'm in it
you guys know you get responses
sometimes like I'm in it Gary you don't
get it my CFO sucks I'm like no you
don't get it fire
him you hired him every single thing in
your business that is broken is 100%
your fault you don't like the taxes in
California move to
Texas we found we found the Texas
dude like people people are just so
interesting we're just such we're in a
really challenging spot you know who I
blame eighth place
trophies can somebody ask AI who the
[__] invented that cuz I want to kick
them in the
dick eighth place trophies [__]
everything up we taught kids that losing
was bad we need to teach kids that
losing is
good this is the mistake because what
happens is listen I have 2,000 employees
now at vaynerx globally and a lot of
them are under
28 about 10 seven years ago before this
even became obvious and kind of talked
about even before the whole like and by
the way enough of bashing gen Z the
people that bash gen Z made them bash
[Applause]
yourself like you're mad at your TW like
I get all these conversations like Gary
my son he's a real messy I'm like H old
25 I'm like we start talking because I
this is interesting to me and I care and
I want to help and then you find out
that their parents paying for their 25y
olds
life I'm like you want and they're
complaining that their kids not on like
like it's impossible it's impossible to
be hungry when you're
fed you know and listen everyone's got
different circumstances I'm talking
General and everybody's got their own
[__] I get that but the eth place trophy
thing killed us we made people scared I
don't know if you're paying attention
that's all that's going on here in
business and life it's just one game of
fear versus love and fears got a lot of
momentum how many people here are happy
make
noise
I definitely do not believe that by the
way that was some loud ass like not
everyone's [__] happy but I'll take
it so let me given that everyone here is
happy I don't know why the [__] you're
here
then but are you thank you I love you
back for that but listen if you're happy
one thing i' one thing if you're
following of what I'm doing and I think
this is an issue and I'd like to
actually challenge it especially because
I feel the Vib and I'm happy so many
people are happy if you're happy you
have a
responsibility what's happening is
negativity is so
loud and so on the offense and happiness
is
content happiness is chilling with their
eight friends and staying away from it
the reason I'm so in and willing to deal
with the ridicule and the judgment and
all the [__] that comes along with being
out there like that is because I feel
like I have a sense of responsibility my
mom really built me like that and I feel
guilt even sometimes let alone gratitude
and that's why I take on the
responsibility to put out the [__] I do
if there's that many people in this room
that are so happy please change up your
content a little bit and add a post
about happiness how to find it how you
found it how you see other things start
posted more happy [__] you into
that
seriously cuz cuz since this whole
room's
happy we're getting drained the [__] out
out we're drowned
out and so we we really really like if
it's so good to contribute to society
and there's so many ways people have
different resources some people use
money and they do that that's amazing
some people do it through service but
like if you're happy start showing more
people that you could be successful and
happy there's so much [__] that [__] me
up like nice guys finish last do you
know how [__] up that
is that's another person we need to
find who invented that [__] we taught an
entire generation multiple Generations
that you can't be successful and nice do
you know how crazy that is that's insane
the negativity because it goes 10 times
more they want a paent it's horrible I'm
not worried about other people I'm not
talking about other people I understand
what people are doing I focus on you
[__] what everyone else is
doing
I know what everyone's
doing I'm asking y'all what are you
doing what do you want to do to me it's
re if you want to grow there is a
incredible obvious historical framework
to this the only way you can grow is you
have to have
energy if for example if you spend one
minute of
energy on envy and jealousy of someone
who's winning in your space you're
losing when I see other people in my
space win I'm happy for them the world
is abundant they're
not my friends nobody's taking
yours no one yeah you might lose a deal
to someone somebody else might sell a
shirt to someone you sell shirts listen
to me no one is taking yours you're
taking
yours I will cuz there's plenty in the
back you're taking
yours this goes back to accountability
you want to grow It's Just Energy go
into your cocoon make it [__] flowery
and sunshiny and happy start limiting
your negativity listen I have a family
listen my family is from the USSR the
majority of my family is fairly negative
and and that's because that was the
world we lived in we lived in a 70-year
jail it was a bad place people no of
course Russians drink Vodka to the face
it was [__]
horrible all my f most of my family died
before I met them I very small family it
was [__] up I started looking at
Family Photos when I was a kid at like
13 I finally realized like we didn't
have that many pictures but we look you
know family gathers I was like wait a
minute there's not one [__] person
smiling in any of these [__] pictures
it was that [__] up I got real lucky
because out of that whole crew the most
important one was the reverse my mind
pure positivity but not the eighth place
trophy [__] when I got out of line she
punched me in the
face that's another thing I think kids
should be fighting
again when I think about what you know
why everyone's so nasty to each other on
social media because not enough people
have been punched in the [__]
Mount the N cuz I promise you I don't
talk [__] mainly because of the
neighborhoods I grew up in and if you
went too far you got a [__] punch in
the [__] face these eth Place
trophies these C everyone's a zoo animal
we're over coddling of course people
have anxiety by the time they go to the
real world they're like What's this
[__] my friends that's
us maybe not an everything but all of us
have a vulnerability too I had a real re
real relevation about 5 seven years ago
everything that's been bad in my life
personal and professional was because I
didn't have cander I wasn't able Gary ve
on stage what I just did that's [__]
cander I can talk cander when I'm
talking wide I can talk about parenting
when I'm wide I would never talk to any
of you one-on-one about parenting that's
you and your family you know your
Dynamics I'm talking generalities up
here and the more I liked you the more
it was unlikely for me to give you
cander I didn't care about the money
enough so it wasn't about like me paying
someone who sucked [__] right and it
[__] me up was a huge gash it was in a
world where I think I got very fortunate
with DNA and Circumstance it was my
kryptonite and I work on it and I'm a
four right now and it's made a huge
impact on my business the last three
years and my personal life and I'm a
four and most things I'm at eight nine
or 10 for real if I'm scoring my own
homework you know and I'm a four but
going from one to four has Chang CH my
life and for a lot of you it is patience
but that patience is grounded in
insecurity you need to figure out who
you're trying to
impress who you understand once you
understand who you're trying to impress
your life will
change and the problem is for half of us
we're trying to impress someone who
isn't emotionally strong enough to give
us the flowers we're looking
for
[Music]
you
know and a lot of us have been
conditioned I've been conditioned as the
oldest son of an immigrant family whose
dad worked every minute that I got to
take care of everything but that leads
to resentment everything's always on my
back so I've had to work on that
nobody's got it great or everyone has it
great 730 million people on Earth do not
have access to clean
water I'm on the board of Charity water
we build Wells in Africa in parts of
India it's insane to me 730 million
people almost 10% of the humans on this
Earth cannot get to a glass of clean
water in 24 hours and and it's
2023 and you're complaining get your
Wi-Fi is a little slow
today you know like what are we doing
accountability somebody saw me the other
day in the off in the airport with like
a Starbucks C like an expensive coffee
and they were razing me because I used
to put out a lot of content of like
don't buy $7 coffees but he misheard it
then I I broke it down we had a nice
little chat he's like Gary V what the
[__] and I was like bro no no no
remember the videos I said if you
complain about not having money I don't
complain about not having money I'm like
if you complain about not having money
and you're buying $7 coffees you're
[__] up if you complain about not
having money and you're taking Uber four
times a day you're [__] up if you
complain about not having money and you
got an $800 belt that's a [__]
problem but I know why people do that
it's their little moments of Joy I get
it right it's how they want to project I
get it but this goes back to the biggest
theme that I hope you didn't gloss over
if I could get all of you to leave this
and ask yourself who are you trying to
impress I got real lucky I just want
wanted to impress my mom and the only
thing she thought was cool is if you
were nice so I got real lucky I know not
everyone has that but I promise you you
need to figure that out because most of
you are making almost every decision
based on that and the second you decode
that and break that [__] down and
reframe it it will change your [__]
life and then you can worry about the
free tactics you can find in the
internet to build your [__]
business you don't need to buy any
course or go anywhere you don't need
none of that [__] you need this and the
free [__] on the internet but this is
the [__] problem thank
[Music]
you